hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and today i will be taking
another
deep dive into the very latest crazy
events
in the boku no heroes story the final
showdown of what is probably the best
arc in the entire series
has just begun all of the main players
are now on the main stage and things are
getting hotter than ever
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
boku no hero videos and you want us to
keep it going
please leave a like and comment on this
video
you might think that it doesn't matter
but it actually helps a lot because each
like and comment
tells the youtube algorithm to recommend
this video to more
people and if you haven't already you
can also subscribe to this channel
and click that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been
warned now in my previous boku no hero
video about the dark transformation of
deku's character
i talked about how much this insane war
arc has been affecting the entire hero
society
and heroes like deku in particular this
installment of the story definitely
played into this
even further but it also seemed to
stress that the villains have
changed as well in fact many of the main
villains in the story
are nothing short of monsters at this
point
and that goes double for shigaraki as
gigantomachia
rampages through jakku some of the
heroes and hero students who are able to
fly
have been tasked with finding the heroes
who are fighting shigeraki
at the ruins of the hospital since
shigaraki's quirk
jammed all the electronic signals in the
area the heroes have to inform endeavour
aizawa deku bakugo and the others that
makia
is almost there and since shigaraki's
decay can destroy everyone who is stuck
on the ground the heroes with flying
abilities were specifically selected
for this mission neji rehado is one of
the heroes embarking upon this mission
but ingenium aka eida decides to join
her
even though as a hero who cannot fly he
was supposed to stay away from shigaraki
ida agrees to take any punishment that
might come his way for
breaking the rules because he simply
cannot stand by
and do nothing in this crucial moment
three of his class 1a classmates have
gone to face shigaraki
and none of them have returned this
includes deku bakugo and shoto
and as the class representative ida
feels responsible for their safety
but more than that ida has been rescued
by these guys
in the past like when deku and shoto
saved his life from staying
so ida decides that he must act
rules be damned the fact that the class
1a representative who is usually a
stickler for the rules and regulations
is willing to defy the rules in this
situation
really speaks to what extraordinary and
drastic circumstances the heroes are
currently
facing this even further stresses
how much this war arc has changed the
hero society
and each individual member of that
society including
ida back on the battlefield shoto
manages to grab deku
and he brings him down to safety
alongside bakugou
and some distance away from shigaraki
however
even though in the last few chapters it
seemed like shigaraki was pretty much
done for
and even all for one told him that he
must take a break and recuperate
shigeraki simply refuses to give up
he uses that weird tendril quirk from
all for one to hoist himself
up off the ground and move around like
some sort of grotesque spider
on the inside all for one again tells
him that he must take a break
but shigaraki refuses to let all for one
tell him what to do
you really have to respect shigaraki
here even when he is no longer able to
stand
on his own two feet he finds a way to
keep fighting
he is that determined truly a monster
in many ways shigaraki really is the
evil mirror image of
deku as motivated as deku is to be a
hero and save
everyone shigaraki seems to be equally
motivated to be a villain
and to destroy the entire hero society
both of them are willing to risk their
lives
push themselves to the limit and
completely ignore
all common sense nejire and ida soon
arrive on the battlefield and nigeria
launches her energy waves at spider
shigaraki while ita informs the others
that gigantomachia is
almost there the heroes tell ita and
negra to help evacuate the casualties
and that is when ida and haddo realized
just how many heroes have already been
seriously injured
on this battlefield aizawa bakugo
endeavour gran torino and of course
ryukyu
najira's mentor are all among the
injured
and man negede is definitely not pleased
when she sees
ryukyu's condition for what might be the
first time in the story
negera seems genuinely pissed deku says
that while the others should get medical
help
he will stay behind and keep shigaraki
away
from everyone else since we know that
shigaraki is specifically interested in
deku
deku doesn't want to be evacuated since
shigaraki would then just keep following
him and that would put
others in danger this of course is deku
being deku again
he is more than willing to sacrifice
himself and his own safety
if it means protecting others but shoto
seems to believe that retreating
at this moment might be a mistake the
heroes now have a chance to
actually take out shigaraki shigaraki's
regeneration has
clearly slowed and he is vulnerable so
this could be their best
chance to defeat him before his backup
arrives
and so as this epic standoff on the main
battlefield is taking place
and as we are all wondering whether the
heroes will fight or retreat or some
combination of the two
the focus of the chapter suddenly
switches back to the fight between toga
and ochako in the previous chapter we
saw toga lure ochako into a trap
and then land on top of her knife in
hand but
ochako has gotten stronger since she
last met toga
and she manages to flip toga and throw
her off
while ochoko is trying to figure out a
way to defeat toga as soon as possible
so that she can continue with the
evacuation
toga seems to be more interested in
having like a deep psychological chit
chat about
love and friendship and all that fun
stuff
a pretty classic yandere move not gonna
lie toga explains her warped view of the
world
to ochako she says that when she thinks
about the people she likes
she has a strong urge to become like
them
and due to the nature of her quirk this
makes toga want to drain
all of their blood toga's desire for
blood is connected to her feelings for
other people
and it is connected on a biological
level to the blood craving nature of her
quirk
so whereas a normal person would show
their affection to a friend or a crush
in a usual way like talking to them or
asking them out or calling them a
baka toga's way of expressing that
affection is by
sucking out that person's blood
potentially even to the point of
killing them we know that in her
childhood toga was constantly forced to
repress her desire
and her fascination with blood and her
parents in particular were
adamant about forcing her to be quote
unquote normal
toga did manage to repress her urges for
a while but eventually they manifested
and she became
a social outcast she was rejected and
feared by everyone
she was hunted by the police and the
heroes and the only people who accepted
her were the most
twisted of villains like her good friend
twice
togo then tells ochoko about the time
that she awakened her quirk during the
meta liberation army arc
when she was cornered by chito sakizuki
and the other members of the army
toga was able to not only turn into
ochako physically but she was also
able to activate ochako's quirk zero
gravity she then used zero gravity to
kill chitose
and other members of the army before
making her escape
toga says that she can now copy the
quirks of the people she likes
and she adds that this made her super
happy
so maybe toga can only copy the quirks
of people that she feels close to
because she likes them meaning that she
can't copy the quirks of like random
strangers on the street
if she just takes some of their blood
with that said though
toga really really likes deku
i know that we've been led to believe
that one for all cannot be copied
but if anyone can figure out a way
around that it is the absolutely insane
toga
if she ever learns to copy one for all
or even just like
one component of one for all such as
black whip
all the heroes will be in big trouble
but
toga may not even need one for all at
all for all we know
she may have already consumed the blood
of other villains with powerful quirks
so she may already have some surprise
quirk tricks up her sleeve
toga was definitely closed twice and if
at some point twice let her take his
blood
we could be getting sad man's parade
toga edition
at some point in the future and that
would be truly terrifying
as toga is telling all of these things
to ochoko she seems to think that her
story is going to have a positive effect
on ochako toga seems to want her to know
that it was the power of their
friendship that allowed her to use zero
gravity
in such a crucial moment essentially
toga's feelings of friendship towards
ochoko ended up saving her life
by lending her the ability to use zero
gravity
however ochoko isn't happy about this
at all in fact she is shocked that toga
would talk so casually about
killing people using her quirk and
ochako doesn't
understand what point toga is trying to
make
with all of this talk by the way as this
convo between the two of them is going
on
they are moving around the house
fighting and breaking everything in
sight
i am focusing mostly on the conversation
itself but this is definitely not some
stationary casual talk between bffs
then in a pretty on the nose moment
regarding the feelings that both of
these girls
share for deku toga grabs almight's
keychain that deku had given to
ochako for christmas ochoko then gets
upset
and chases toga and the keychain here is
an obvious metaphor for deku
both girls are figuratively fighting
over deku
since as toga mentioned they both like
him
ochoko decides that there is no more
time to waste
she must take toga down as the two of
them stumbled through the different
rooms
ochako touched a bunch of furniture she
then uses zero gravity to make that
furniture
levitate and she controls the furniture
using a bunch of strings that protrude
from her hero costume she attempts to
take toga down using this move
but toga reveals that she has been
holding back this entire time
in fact as i mentioned earlier ever
since she was a child
toga was forced to hold back her desires
and especially the part about her
craving blood
and being fascinated by it it really
seems like toga is looking for some form
of sympathy
and understanding from this girl whom
she considers to be her friend
but ochako has no sympathy for toga
toga has a craving for hurting others
and that is something that someone like
ochoko could never sympathize with
instead of understanding toga
or relating to her ochako vows to make
her take responsibility
for her villainous actions i think that
this is the core of toga's state of mind
at the moment toga doesn't seem to
realize that there is anything
inherently wrong
with her actions she doesn't seem to
understand that hurting other people to
satisfy her desires
or to achieve her goals is actually
something bad
since toga thinks of ochako as her
friend she wants ochoko to understand
her desires but ochoko can never do that
she is a hero and she is committed to
saving people not hurting them
in this sense toga and a hero like
ochako
or deku are simply not speaking the same
language
their core values and beliefs are
completely different
and they will never see eye to eye they
can never
really be friends after hearing ochako's
rebuke of her entire life philosophy
toga seems to finally understand the
truth and
tears appear in her eyes tsuyu suddenly
breaks into the house to help ochoko
and in all the confusion toga uses her
ability to become virtually invisible to
get away as she leaves
toga drops deku's keychain and this is
also symbolic
because it represents toga dropping her
illusion of ever becoming
friends with a hero like ochako or deku
in her own mind toga was pretending that
her and ochoko were just two girls who
liked the same guy
and she thought that one day they could
just hang out as friends and talk about
love together but now toga seems to
finally understand
that this fantasy is impossible they can
never be
on the same side toga has her
answer and she is returning to the
villains
at least that's what it seems like the
final pages of the chapter
show the battlefield among the ruins of
jakku hospital
as nejire and the others try to bring
down spider shigaraki
gigantomachia finally smashes his way
onto the battlefield itself all of the
big players of this arc
are now on the same stage shigaraki
deku pakugo endeavor dabi kigantomakia
shoto they're all here the final
showdown
is about to begin man this was
crazy even though this chapter was
primarily a setup for the coming
showdown between all the main villains
and all the main heroes
i did enjoy the conversation between
toga and ochako
and it is fascinating to explore toga's
twisted psychology
that said i am much more excited for the
final showdown to begin
i mean dobby is here in the same place
as
shoto and endeavor makia is also here
and ready to give it his all
for shigaraki and the already exhausted
heroes
are now in big big trouble what do you
guys think is going to happen
next is makia about to wreck the heroes
or is that sleeping agent about to kick
in
is best genius about to hop out of the
helicopter
and use that giant fabric to tie makia
down
and what is really happening with
shigaraki can the heroes bring down
this monster or is he just getting
started
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more boku no
hero right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
anime opera or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the way that youtube
works now you really have to go through
the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just the
way it goes
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
liam thompson disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king wrathwin deora red haired
raven
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mano
admirath
and chris torley finally thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan steelers anatoly
kazatsuki
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci
jessica califond alicia octor hinokamian
water bonnie parks florian
joanne garcia mcshamus deadly saint and
high school dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you